hi guys for about a month now i've been
sitting on some really exciting and
exclusive news about the new stargate tv
series
finally my hands have been untied and
i'm able to share it with you
this is scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie
channel
so about a month ago i did a video about
how stargate was officially returning to
our tv screens and i can't really be
much happier about being able to tell
you that that video is actually
wrong or at very least it is now
giant freaking robot released this story
a little over a year ago saying that mgm
had greenlit a live action tv series and
an animated tv series
now it turns out according to a source
and i'll tell you about in a second that
that story was actually true
but
isn't any more
the mgm executive producer in charge of
written tv shows basically non-reality
tv shows
steve stark
had
requested brad wright begin working on
these two tv series he wanted brad
wright to create a format for a live
action tv series and an animated tv
series
this was just over two years ago when
mgm was beginning its process of being
put up for sale according to my source
mgm always knew the stargate was a bit
of a sleeping giant and that when the
when the negotiations begun for the sale
to amazon initially mgm was reluctant
they didn't want to sell
everything all in one bundle to amazon
they thought they could either
get an investor in that would allow them
to carry on producing material of their
own
or break up the business into smaller
chunks and maybe generate more money
however
then
cove it happened and then it became
quickly obvious that actually selling to
amazon was their only really viable
option
basically their assets from a tv movie
point of view broken down into two main
sections the back catalog that they
already own and the intellectual rights
that they own
obviously for mgm james bond is by far
their biggest franchise
but over the last 20 years the second
largest franchise within their catalogue
of material is stargame
they always knew that amazon were
interested in this because amazon had
been showing the stargate cv series on
their platform on prime for the last few
years and have always done really good
sales and views
they knew amazon were interested but
as only a back catalog
it has a limited value stargate though
as an existing possible new tv show
holds more value so brad wright was
instructed to begin that process however
that all changed in march when steve
sparks lost his job
and the whole idea of a tv show and
animated series very much in line with
what amazon had done with star trek and
what i think mgm thought amazon would
want them to do has now been scrapped
michael wright mgm's new chief executive
of scripted tv
never liked this idea
he apparently believes that mgm don't
really have the production capabilities
to produce a high enough quality
animated series
he wants the new project to go in line
with what mgm already does and already
does well
but i'll tell you a bit more about that
in a minute
so where is this information coming from
right basically i did a video like i
said about a year ago that video did
really well i got 100 000 views it did
phenomenally well and i thank you all
for watching
and from that video i got a little
comment meant just happened to say this
actually isn't really true anymore
this was true about six months ago but
it's been scrapped i was intrigued by
that because he was so confident and
clear about what he was saying he was
you know he wasn't just sort of saying
like i don't think this is true he said
it's not true
so i started a little conversation with
him
now over the last month he has told me
lots of information and
he's basically unable to share that i
wanted him to come on and actually have
an interview and a conversation with him
but he said there's no chance he can do
that with his company he has actually
signed a non-disclosure agreement he's
not allowed to share this information so
i thought okay well he works for mgm
turns out no he doesn't
he's actually an accountant now at that
point i started to sort of go
how do you know anything then
well he's an accountant for a legal firm
that legal firm does a lot of the legal
work and contract writing for mgm
whenever a new project starts
they have to deal with all the
individual little contracts that set up
that so the lighting company needs to be
a contract the food truck company the
nsp contract as well as the individual
stars um there needs to be contracts
regarding the writers and and so on and
so on hundreds of lots and lots of
little contracts and these all need to
be produced by this legal firm they also
then have accountants that basically do
all the math and check that everything
adds up he is one of those accountants
and he has been involved in the mgm sale
to amazon
he said from day one amazon were very
very interested in stargate they called
it the sleeping giant of sci-fi if they
said look at what we've managed to do
with star trek over the last few years
we want to do that we want to do it with
stargate they see the stargate franchise
potentially being easily as big as star
trek so he's actually seen or know of
people who have seen lots of these
proposals
every time a new idea is brought forward
one of the first things the legal
company do is prepare pre-contracts and
they start thinking about how much
production etc will cost
a lot of that actually goes through this
legal firm
now i have been able to confirm that one
the chap i was talking to is actually
who he says he is he was not just some
person sat in his mom's basement pulling
my chain so that was my first thing so
he is who he says he is
i was also able to independently verify
he does work for who he says he works
for and i was able to verify that
actually
this company does the work for mgm that
he says it did so i've got no reason to
disbelieve him but obviously he's making
some quite big claims and why would he
tell me at the end of the day
well he basically was only having a
conversation with me and he promised me
made me promise not to tell anyone but
last week he gave me permission he said
okay you can tell anyone just don't use
my name and don't tell me there's
certain things i'm not allowed to tell
you but anyway we'll move on from that
so brad wright has been quite openly
talking about how he's been developing a
new stargate series
my source says that that was very much
on purpose mgm very early on realized
amazon were very interested in the
stargate franchise but
as it was only a back catalogue its
value was limited
however stargate as a proposal move was
for a new tv show
and a tv show that people are actually
excited to hear about and to watch
held more value and could in theory get
more money for mgm
obviously james bond is by far their
biggest
franchise
and there's a lot of excitement around
james bond at the moment because daniel
craig is finished
they wanted something similar a hype
around stargate so brad wright started
talking quite openly about developing
this tv show he has spoken to amanda
tapping about potentially directing he
has spoken to michael shanks about
potentially directing and none of that
has been kept secret and the internet
has been abuzz with it
the giant freaking robot story probably
was purposefully leaked because at the
time it was true and again they wanted
people talking about stargate because
they wanted to drive the amazon interest
in buying the franchise and maybe
getting a little bit more money out of
them
it worked
amazon look at social media movement
they look at numbers they show stargate
on prime at the moment and it still gets
really good numbers you can't actually
get sg1 on prime in the uk even though
the show's 20 years old you have to pay
for it and people still do
stargate sg1 still produces really good
money and numbers for amazon and they're
not stupid they see those numbers
so mgm did a little bit of a con job
they pretended that this was maybe
further along the process of development
than it really was
and they got amazon on the hook so in
march 2021
michael wright took over from steve
spark as the executive producer at mgm
for scripted productions
one of the first things he did
apparently
according to my source was scrap the
stargate idea
apparently amazon executives are not
interested in doing a lower deck style
animated tv series and neither of the
interested in any sort of anime animated
series
they don't believe that the interest is
quite there with stargate just yet and
they need to build up to that so the
plan that michael wright has put
together is to produce a straight to
amazon prime movie of stargate first
there will then be a separate with
separate actors
10 at least 10 episode series following
shortly afterwards the plan being that
the movie will create a lot of hype and
get a lot of momentum going that will
then be followed through with the series
that will be a similar story to the
stargate movie but separate which will
hopefully then turn into
multiple straight to amazon prime movies
the idea being that these 10 episode
stand-alone series will be one story arc
like we see with picard etcetera now the
plan is also to have as many of the
characters from sg1 and atlantis to
return
as far as i'm aware no actors
related to sgu have been approached
however there have been apparently
pre-contract negotiations with amanda
tapping and michael shanks
and we also might see teal come back but
other actors have also been approached
but that has not been confirmed by my
source
so what do you guys think
we all know giant freaking robot is a
massive pile of demon crap i wish i'd
known that when i first read the story
and got over excited about stargate
returning but i didn't um
is this source genuine from everything i
can see it seems to be does it make
sense that amazon would want this
project to return does it make sense
that amazon would see stargate really as
a sleeping giant of sci-fi something
that they can really exploit and that
may potentially make a couple of movies
and a couple of tv series out of
something that they can grow into a
franchise similar to that of star trek
do you guys think
please leave a comment let me know and
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe and hit that bell
notification and i will be keeping a
really close eye on this story and if
anything changes i will get it out to
you straight away
right thanks guys and i'll see you next
time
[Music]